[Musik]
das ist teuer
letzte Woche habe ich genau das gleiche
gekauft heute kostet es fast das
Doppelte
solche Diskussionen hören wir hier an
fast jedem Stand auf dem Markt in Tunis
die Menschen sind wütend denn die Preise
für Lebensmittel steigen immer weiter
hier ist nichts mehr
du bekommst nichts für dein Geld
du kannst von deinem Lohn gerade mal
Strom und Wasser bezahlen aber auch
Fleisch auf Fisch auf all das müssen wir
verzichten
der Staat hat kein Geld und das
tunesische Volk hat nicht genug zu essen
keine Milch kann Zucker kein Öl von all
dem nichts
zwischen all den Menschen hier die
versuchen die Preise runterzuhandeln
treffen wir Hascher und begleiten Sie
beim Einkaufen seit dem Beginn des
Krieges in der Ukraine wird es auch für
Menschen wie sie aus der Mittelschicht
immer schwieriger ihr tägliches Leben zu
finanzieren
vorher hatte eine normale Familie 300
bis 400 dinabudget pro Monat für
Grundnahrungsmittel wie Gemüse und
solche Dinge
für die alltäglichen Einkäufe reicht
jetzt nicht mal mehr das Doppelte aus
[Musik]
umgerechnet sind das knapp 300 Euro für
mehr als Essen bleibt da im Monat nicht
viel Fleisch und Importprodukte sind
hier inzwischen Luxusware geworden
auf dem Weg durch die Stadt fällt uns
auf dass besonders viel bei dem
Bäckereien los ist keine leeren Regale
wie im Sommer die Menschen kommen mit
vollen Tüten wieder raus
[Musik]
es gibt wieder genug Brot hier in den
Bäckereien von Tunis und das zu einem
fixen Brotpreis trotz Inflation der von
der Regierung festgelegt ist das geht
momentan bei sich Tunesien noch einmal
viel Geld geliehen hat um die
weizenimporte zu bezahlen eine
kurzfristige Lösung in einem Land das
sich immer weiter auf den
wirtschaftlichen Kollaps zu bewegt
tunesien hat bisher 60 bis 80 Prozent
seines weichweizens aus der Ukraine und
Russland importiert aber der Weizenpreis
auf dem Weltmarkt steigt und das ohnehin
schon hoch verschuldete Tunesien kann
die bestellte Ware nicht mehr bezahlen
zwei weizenschüsse hat die EU-Kommission
schon finanziert jetzt verhandelt die
Regierung mit dem Internationalen
Währungsfonds um einen Kredit in
Milliardenhöhe mit den Auswirkungen der
aktuellen Lebensmittelkrise und des
Krieges mussten wir unseren Etat für
dieses Jahr um 1,3 Milliarden Dinar
erhöhen deshalb haben wir uns an
Geldgeber wie die Weltbank und an die
Europäische Union gewandt um unsere
kostendecken zu können vor allem für die
subventionierten Produkte hauptsächlich
Getreide Presse ich beim
wir fragen uns wie subventioniert die
tunesische Regierung diese Lebensmittel
vor allem Brot und wie lange kann sie
sich das in ihrer wirtschaftlichen Lage
noch leisten in einem Randbezirk von
Tunis finden wir eine Großbäckerei Mehl
scheint genug da zu sein so weitermachen
können sie trotzdem nicht mehr lange
erzählt uns der Chef
vom Staat subventioniert werden
normalerweise unsere Ausgaben für Benzin
Hefe und so weiter die von Tag zu Tag
mehr werden denn der Staat legt den
Preis fest und wir können das Brot nicht
teurer verkaufen aber jetzt hat uns der
Start seit 14 Monaten unsere
Subventionen nicht bezahlt
der Unmut im Land wächst die Bäcker
rufen zum Streik auf und während
Tunesien immer weiter in der
Wirtschaftskrise versinkt gehen die
Menschen auf die Straße immer mehr
fordern den Rücktritt von Präsident
Kayser jetzt der hat im Sommer 2021 die
Regierung entmachtet und sichert sich
immer mehr Befugnisse um defacto allein
zu regieren
wir machen uns auf den Weg Richtung
algerische Grenze hier auf dem Land
wollen wir mehr über den vom Staat
Gelenken Getreidemarkt Tunesiens
erfahren und was der Ukraine Krieg
verändert
auf seinem Feld treffen wir Schafe den
twati er baut Weizen vor allem an um
seine Tiere damit zu füttern und auch
das wird für ihn immer schwieriger
bereits bevor der Krieg in der Ukraine
begonnen hat sind die Preise ja schon
angestiegen
aber der Krieg hat die Lage jetzt noch
weiter verschlimmert
jetzt ist es so dass man selbst für viel
Geld überhaupt keine Düngemittel mehr
bekommt
Weizen aus dem man Mehl für Brot machen
kann baut er kaum an das hat sich bisher
nicht gelohnt weil Tunesien in den
letzten Jahren immer mehr Weizen aus dem
Ausland importiert hat theoretisch
könnte hier auf den Flächen viel mehr
angebaut werden hier in der Provinz chen
dubar im Nordwesten des Landes ist ein
Großteil der landwirtschaftlichen
Flächen von Tunesien die Bauern mit
denen wir gesprochen haben wissen aber
nicht mehr so richtig wie sie
weitermachen sollen wenn die
Subventionierungen vom Staat weiter
ausbleiben und die Düngemittel auf dem
Weihnachtsmarkt weiter so teuer sind wie
jetzt viele von ihnen haben uns erzählt
dass sie schon jetzt darüber nachdenken
in naher Zukunft ihre Betriebe aufgeben
zu müssen
vor allem die Viehbauern leiden durch
den Ukraine Krieg sind auch Futtermittel
wie Soja immer teurer geworden einige
von javez Nachbarn haben schon große
Teile ihrer Herden verkaufen müssen
mit meinen 54 Jahren kann ich keinen
anderen Job mehr machen
ich bin zwar gerade dabei den Hof an
meine Tochter zu übergeben aber erstmal
muss ich einsparen um den Hof überhaupt
am Leben zu halten wenn meine Tochter
ist dann nicht schafft Gewinne zu machen
wird sie aufgeben müssen
den Bauern hier fehlt eine Vision eine
Vorgabe vom Staat wie die tunesische
Landwirtschaft künftig aussehen soll das
Land ist wie gelähmt die Regierung ist
damit beschäftigt den Staatsbankrott
irgendwie abzuwenden und den
Machtapparat umzubauen und die
Demokratie zerbricht
wenn wir die wirtschaftlichen Probleme
hier mit dem Geld dass wir vom
Internationalen Währungsfonds
hoffentlich bekommen nicht in den Griff
kriegen dann steigt das Risiko dass die
Demokratie scheitert immer weiter ich
checkt oder Demokrat
die globalen Auswirkungen des
ukrainekrieges haben die
Wirtschaftskrise hier noch weiter
verschärft Tunesien einst Musterland des
arabischen Frühlings jetzt haben wir
hier Menschen getroffen die in eine sehr
unsichere Zukunft blicken Essen wird
immer teurer die Menschen leiden und
suchen einen Verantwortlichen einen
Schuldigen hier ist es der Staat die
Demokratie bröckelt auch in Serbien
leiden Bürgerinnen und Bürger unter
extremen Preissteigerungen und geben
auch der EU die Schuld dafür warum dem
sind meine Kollegin Britta Hilpert und
ihr Team nachgegangen
wie sehr die Menschen momentan in der
Ukraine leiden besonders in Hinblick auf
den kalten Winter das zeigt meine
Kollegin Katrin Eigendorf hier im Video
hat euch das Video gefallen dann lasst
gerne einen like da und abonniert diesen
Kanal